hello everyone I hope you're having a
good time
well for years 40 years of storytelling
mixing myth mythology legend technology
in this extraordinary cinematic form I'd
be very honored to play quake on gin in
the Phantom Menace I'm actually here on
location in the Canadian Rockies we're
making a movie a very unofficial movie
about Jar Jar Binks what happened to
judge on the spoiler alert he did go to
the dark side have a great time everyone
may the force be with you
men especially with you always take care
thanks George for giving it out
paternity and letting me ride it out
through at least three episodes which I
could be there so I could sign
everything you brought from either side
and just say hey to everybody in person
and while you're all sitting there I
know you're all in my corner on this we
know Jedi's and fall from incredible
Heights and survived so apparently I am
not dead yes I have two appendages right
now but we know the long and rich
history of Star Wars characters
reappearing with new appendages and
being stronger and better than they ever
work mace windu is awaiting his return
let's make it happen
Cathy he's sitting right there I
do all you got to do is say the word
fear so on screen I hope
happy Star Wars week continues everyone
allegedly in Neeson's keeping the dream
of Darth Jar Jar alive I bet somebody
off-screen from Lucasfilm had to explain
that theory to him see there are people
that think the dark Jar Jar was
originally supposed to be a syst
character then within the same breath
mace windu douses all the hopes of your
mace windu Snoke theories even though he
says he's still alive so he's out there
somewhere
the theory if you don't understand the
mace windu theory he kind of explains
the version of it when he's saying hey
I'm still alive Jedi had been known to
survive falls from great heights so when
they were least behind-the-scenes
pre-production on Snoke he had this
giant scar down the middle of his face
it looks like this in the final version
of the film but it's a little easier to
see on this model people were theorizing
that this could be mace windu post fight
with Palpatine in during the Palpatine
panel which I'll include footage up here
where he explains Darth Plagueis the
wise they sort of winked at that moment
too but the real reason that samuel
l.jackson isn't in the new films is
mostly because they're doing new
characters he'd be a very old person now
and by the logic of the series most of
them had been hunted down by Darth Vader
so at some point Darth Vader would have
found mace windu but just taking samuel
l.jackson it is where the dream is alive
he's out there somewhere so there's
always the in-between movies that's how
they do stuff like the obi-wan movie how
you could bring back people like Darth
Maul there was a really interesting
Darth Maul panel where Rey Park came out
there are a lot of ways to bring all
this back but let me know what you guys
think of all this and what other panels
you guys want me to post I'll be posting
the last Jedi panel in my trailer video
tomorrow for whatever footage they drop
from episode 8 but here's that Darth
Plagueis explainer from Palpatine
himself every time he got more powerful
I got more tempting of Anakin he got a
bigger office and they won't CGI they
were real I walk into the studio got my
god where are you and but then George
said I think we've had enough of offices
let's go to the theater so on this
Friday that I talked about we had two
chairs just like this either size
Anakin's chair my chair and a green
screen obviously everything was going to
be added later
and I had learnt it we didn't have time
to rehearse the end of Friday and he he
was there and was doing it with me
obviously Georgia will be on you all day
today and Southwest for was much of the
day left and there will be on you
hanging on Monday I thought what can we
both be on Monday okay my voice it gets
better enough and he said no don't worry
you know if we don't look at will do it
again on Monday but I'd like you to do
it along seem as you know
don't stop they'll throw you a line if
you need one but don't stop that's all
to do with continuity and so on and in
front of me were to just where that box
is now there were two cameraman two of
the best in the business who slid along
on this moving track every now and again
and I knew I had their utmost
concentration and brilliance they were
down below me because I'm though trying
to make me look at hideous as possible
you know it nothing lots of gel and
everything else and I did the scene
about 20 times and I I didn't need to
call for a line miraculously and what
helped me with Aidan's fantastic
concentration on this side the to guide
and my ability to ignore mobile phones
which were tossed in submissively from
the video village I knew I shouldn't
stop so it was a very strange day and I
thought when we finished well we'll
certainly be doing all that again on
Monday and George said no I've got what
I wanted on Monday we'll be around on
and on Haiti so it's memorable from that
point I also because it's such an
interesting scene one of the longest I
think in the whole saga was a good story
in it the story of Darth Plagueis of
course I wanted to give it my best shot
and I was kind of worrying that with all
that going on and what I've described
you best shots would not be available
however when we put it all together and
maybe the fact that I was a bit in
totally stressed added something to it
so well I saw they do the final version
at the wrong should it happens I didn't
want to kill myself I'm wondering
certain mysteries about the character
like whether Darth Plagueis was his
master
whether he helped create anakin with
midi-chlorians whether he was deformed
or revealed as some of those mysteries
how much of that was told to you by
George Lucas and how much were you
allowed to decide those things for
yourself once again George told me
nothing but he didn't stop me when when
I acted them we didn't discuss any of it
what I liked about the writing in that
scene you know we all make the jokes
about George's writing and Harrison
repeated his famous one this morning and
George has never pretended to be a great
writer but in that scene actually he was
a pretty damn good one
and what the things you've just referred
to as sort of presented to the audience
as questions not as answers so I tried
in as far as possible to leave it
ambiguous but yes what he's hinting at
Palpatine is that this is how Anakin
might have created being created all
those times long time ago that it was a
kind of fiendish plot a kind of like
Jesus in Reverse almost and also the
fact that Plagueis had absolute power
and the power of a life and death which
might be useful as far as time is
concerned but the other thing you had
which is probably the most interesting
thing of all he had no power over his
own death and Palpatine might have been
implying that we killed him and then
that gave him a sense of satisfaction
but also the cycle had to go on as you
know there can only be two at any one
time and also while he's presenting the
case to Anakin in terms of hope and fear
it's a fantastic piece of temptation and
seduction but if you really analyze it -
he's also predicting Anakin's death and
maybe without realizing it
zone so that's why I like the things
ever so rich like Shakespeare I thought
he was just an evil monster you know no
more to be said like like the devil but
even the devil has a backstory so and
with the notion of play goes that opened
up the idea that there might be a
backstory so maybe somebody much younger
than me will play it it would be
interesting so Star Wars we continues
leave all your requests for bonus videos
in the comments below there is a rogue
one giveaway that's happening now that
I'll remind everybody when I post that
trailer video so all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so while you wait
for that to post you can click here for
brand-new Star Wars Celebration and you
can click here for brand new flash thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
me me me me
[Music]